hey youtubers is charlie so this is
going to be my Jon Snow video that I've
been talking about for a while so what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to start at
the end of season 4 with everything we
know that's going on right now and then
just proceed through his logical
progression so this is going to be like
the progression of snow winter is coming
style there are a couple changes we know
already with his character just based on
footage from the trailer i'll try to
explain what those are but just in
general the story line up at the north
will probably the closest to the books
of any of the season five storylines oh
and also real quick reminder the
giveaway this week has been upgraded
because the season four DVD is here or
blu-ray so i'm giving away a copy of the
blu-ray all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video so i'll have more details at
the end of the video so here we go just
careful for spoilers through season 4 on
the show don't worry i'll have an extra
warning whenever we get to book stuff so
starting at the end of season for the
last we see of them is cleaning up the
mess of bodies from the siege at Castle
black John and Sam will have been
preaching white Walker craziness for a
while I don't think everyone believes
them yet but I do think that everyone up
there is really superstitious and and
it's just practical to burn the bodies
it's just an easy way to get rid of all
that Gore just better safe than sorry
Melisandre is up there now she's got
that crazy scary charisma so even if
she's not able to convince everyone of
the threat of the White Walkers I think
they'll be so scared of her and Stannis
that they'll do whatever she says you
also have to remember they have all
those wildlings that they didn't kill
that surrendered they have to figure out
what to do with them add to that the new
group of wildlings that we saw in the
trailer up at hardhome all this stuff
can be found in book five if you haven't
read the books what happens is the story
up at the wall kind of skips book for so
she does have some POV thoughts about
what goes on at the wall but most of the
story takes place during book five so
just because Stannis defeated mance
rayder's army doesn't mean that all
their problems are over you have to
remember there's still a lot of people
in leadership positions up in and around
the wall including wildlings that have
very different opinions about what they
should be doing Stannis is there yes
he's the king he has the army but that
doesn't mean that everybody is going to
be on the same page what does that mean
for Jon Snow mostly it means he's gonna
get dumped on he's going to have the job
of trying to bring everyone together I
mean that Stannis is gold to ultimately
but I think he has bigger concerns on
the brain like he's trying to think more
about what's going on in all of Westeros
not just up at the wall
all let's just take a look at the
leadership up there right now so you
have Stannis and Melisandre then inside
the Nights Watch there's Alliser thorne
yeah no slint I don't think that Bowen
Marsh is going to be in book 5 I haven't
seen him on the cast list he might be
back then inside the wildlings there's
bands Raider and tormund Giantsbane
they're both captives so they're not
quite as big of a threat Rattleshirt is
back too but based on this clip in the
trailer it's hard to tell whether or not
he's part of manses captured army or if
he's up at hardhome then there's this
new character loboda who definitely
looks like he's part of the hard home
group as much as the wildlings have been
defeated there's still a big problem for
the Nights Watch which is going to be
one of the big problems Jon Snow's gonna
have to solve but before they can start
worrying about the White Walkers in the
Bolton's in the south don't forget the
Bolton's are marching on Winterfell so
they're going to be holed up there just
to get into a little bit about you know
where Jon Snow's character might be
headed think a little bit about what's
happening with Denise's character I
think the show regardless of what's
going on in each of the characters heads
the show is pushing for a certain
symmetry between those two you know sort
of like fire and ice quote unquote that
doesn't imply endgame for the series or
a song of ice and fire or anything like
that it's just like a very TV narrative
type thing where the direction of one
character mirrors the direction of
another character so it's like as a
villain Rises so does a hero or two
heroes rise or two family members so the
same type of big beats will be happening
for a lot of the characters even if the
specific circumstances that their inner
are very different so like Daenerys has
to deal with a lot of infighting and
marine between her own forces and the
natives Jon Snow has to deal with a lot
of infighting between the wildlings in
the Nights Watch just to reiterate
though both Jon Snow and donairs have
very different motivations very
different things driving them I like to
think of those two characters Jon Snow
and Daenerys is like accidental leaders
neither one ever really intended to be a
leader but they were thrown into that
situation it just made the best of it
that's really where I think the
similarity ends I mean they both have
made very different choices for very
different reasons when the season starts
really what you want to focus on is how
Jon Snow's new you know leadership
activities change his relationships with
the other big characters like how does
it change his dynamic with Stannis the
other senior members of the Nights Watch
his relationship with Melisandre in the
creepy plans that it looks like she
might have for him I'm definitely
expecting some Gendry type moments with
Melisandre and then you have to remember
John's relationship
with his family and with Winterfell I'm
kind of curious to see if they changed
the opening title sequence if Winterfell
is still burning I mean really it would
have stopped burning a long time ago I
think the fact that they left it in the
intro sequence it's just to be a
reminder of what happened it's not quite
as bad off as Harrenhal was after a god
sent his dragons to destroy it but large
parts of it were burned it's in good
enough shape for Ramsay Bolton to live
there this is actually really good place
to get into book stuff so I'm just going
to add this like spoiler tag up until I
stop talking about book stuff so let's
just talk about some of the changes that
they're probably making based on what we
saw in the trailer at least a Jon Snow's
character so first off it looks like
he's going to get caught her pike story
they're sending him to hardhome to deal
with the crazy wildlings there's a whole
crazy history of heart home that sounds
a lot like what happened at jamestown in
real life that was an early American
colony where everyone mysteriously died
or disappeared or were killed off by
locals and they found evidence of
cannibalism recently so it started out
as this really promising American colony
and it just evolved into absolute chaos
that's pretty much what happened to
ancient heart home in the books but
because it's Game of Thrones it invokes
a lot of supernatural and mystical
elements the town ended up being labeled
as haunted and Wildings never went there
again until now it's amazing what you'll
do when you have an army of White
Walkers marching on you I'll totally
have to do like a separate heart home
video at some point just just because
the history of that place is so cool but
if John is able to win over the
wildlings there and bring them back it
would definitely win him a lot more
support from Stannis it's just an easy
way to cement his leadership the same
way he does in the books as it is I
really don't think Stannis respects
anyone who's a bastard even if they're
the supposed bastard of Ned Stark that
actually brings up an interesting
question that I don't see get asked a
whole lot anymore do you think that the
show is going to address the fact that
Robb Stark in the books legitimize jon
snow before he died they kind of skipped
it on the show so I'm assuming they're
not going to do it there's going to cut
that out as of right now it seems like
the show's pushing Sansa as the heir of
Winterfell if you believe what little
finger has said so far he's going to try
and get it back for as much as John has
his [ __ ] together up at the wall it's
really is a love of family that makes
him want to break his oath and ride for
the Bolton's we already know that the
show cut out the Jane pool character and
replaced her with like the stand in
Miranda she's going to be back in season
five so they might also weave in the
make re a plot with her and when you
look at this map here it seems like
Stannis is mapping Bolton troop
locations so it seems like they are
doing that part of the book like Stannis
will ride on Winterfell they'll probably
just swap a few of the minor characters
okay so spoiler stuff over so i actually
i made like a descending list of
storylines that I think we're at least
changed to most change jon snow / up in
the north then King's Landing with the
surgery stuff Daenerys and marine REM
Braavos and then kind of a type foremost
change between Tyrion in the door and
stuff really like those those last two
storylines have massive chunks major
characters missing whenever we do get to
those episodes i mean i'll try to
include a list of the big changes just
in case you are following along in the
books if there are any like really big
changes you guys want to talk about
specifically I mean just let me know in
the comments I know cutting out young
Griff is a big deal but I think a lot of
the story that they lost will be given
to other characters think of it in like
an eid Rukh storm Gendry type way ok so
just explain the give away a little bit
better so it's a copy of the blu-ray
what I'll probably do is I'll give away
a couple copies between now in the
beginning of the season and then I'll do
it during the season during the actual
episodes congratulations to gangster
virile you're the winner of this week's
giveaway please message me on the back
end of my channel so I get your
communication info so i can find out how
to get you the blu-ray and don't worry
for those wondering the giveaway is open
to international people will find a way
to get you blu-ray somehow if you win
i'm still trying to figure out what next
week's Game of Thrones videos going to
be so feel free to leave requests in the
comments but you can actually click here
for my mega Game of Thrones playlist so
you can see which videos I've already
done and you can click here to get ready
for a walking dead tonight i'll post
that after the episode there so thank
you everyone so much for watching let's
all high five I'll see you guys tonight
you